[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a sci-fi comedy film
called geohazard spoilers ahead watch
out and take
[Music]
care the opening scene of the movie
shows us an advertisement for the
beautiful girl pill the advertisement
claims that the pill is one of a kind
medicine that will reorganize women's
brain nerves and genes turning them into
the most beautiful versions of
themselves for the first year the
beautiful girl pill is sold out
everywhere because of its popularity and
effectiveness any girl who takes it
instantly experiences a change in their
body and face structure suffice it to
say that the pill is very successful if
not revolutionary however in less than
two years of use women begin to feel the
side effects of the drug some get severe
allergic reactions while others go brain
dead within seconds on inspection it is
found that the pill has directly
affected most of the women's brains
making their frontal lobe smaller in
size because of this they show confusion
and difficulty in doing the easiest
tasks in addition they turn emotionally
insatiable and their sense of pain and
pleasure vanishes the effects of the
drug on the human brain and their genes
are far worse than what the scientists
had expected while creating the pill
soon experts find out that the pill has
given rise to a virus called the
beautiful girl virus that is extremely
contagious
the virus is airborne but can only
transfer through an infected person's
kiss any woman infected by it turns into
a zombie-like creature with an instinct
to kiss every man in their way but the
worst part is that every man who gets
kissed gets infected and entirely
transforms into a woman the protagonist
of the movie is a young man named quo k
as the virus spreads rapidly throughout
china quo kay and his friend discuss
what they should do next they receive a
text from kwoke's father and rush home
to find a girl tied in the living room
the father says that the girl is quoki's
brother who has converted into a woman
because of the virus cuocade doesn't
believe it and tries to check the girl's
body but the father claims that he has
already checked and confirmed that it is
a girl creepy the girl was trying to
kiss the father so he tied her to the
chair cuouque's friend says that if the
infected kisses them on any part of
their body the virus will spread
suddenly the father feels a sharp pain
in his chest they find out that quote's
brother has accidentally kissed the
father on his arm the father falls
unconscious but just when they think he
is dead he turns into a beautiful woman
the newly formed girl tries to kiss
cuouque who is happy because all he ever
wanted was a kiss from dad and has to be
restrained by his friend the two accept
the fact that quokay's family is dead
and the women sitting in front of them
are zombies hence they leave them alone
and run outside however they are chased
by an infected woman before they can get
inside the car they get to the streets
but it is too late as the virus has now
spread beyond control the streets are
filled with women who kiss all men in
their sight they try to go to the police
but they have also been infected soon
their phone signals are cut off and they
cannot call anyone for help the two get
stuck on the side of the street
surrounded by women quokai notices that
the infected do not attack beautiful
women so he suggests they go to the
nearest clothing store inside a mall and
disguise themselves but since they are
surrounded cuocay's friend offers to
distract the girls and sacrifice himself
he claims that there is no better way of
dying than being kissed by multiple
women cuoque's friend has a point
moreover he has never fallen in love so
this might be his only chance to ever
get with someone quoke's friend is
depressing having said that the guy
jumps in plain view attracting the
infected ones the girls kiss him as
cuoque runs away to the mall fortunately
for him the mall is completely empty and
so is the clothing store he sits down on
the couch to take a rest and the time
fast forwards to a year later cuouque
still lives in the store which is now
trashed the beautiful girl virus has
taken over china and according to the
radio the survivors have formed camps in
different parts of the country cuocay
however lives alone in the store he
dresses up in women's clothing and wears
a wig to go out and collect food
supplies every once in a while during
one of such ventures he enters a car to
check for supplies only to find a woman
in the back seat trying to save his life
he quickly runs away but an infected
woman follows him to the store while he
checks the supplies she attacks him from
behind but cuoque is saved by a stranger
at the right time the stranger has a
girl with him who surprisingly doesn't
attack them it turns out that she is
infected by the virus but her body
hasn't mutated into a zombie meaning
that she is immune the man introduces
himself as lee wei and the girl as
xiaoki
lee wei is a member of a survival camp
and is on the search for survivors on
his journey he found xiaoki and rescued
her since she is the only woman in china
who is immune he is taking her to a
place called the tower where a group of
scientists has been trying to find a
cure for the beautiful girl virus
xiaoki is an asset to humanity who can
stop the pandemic leeway invites quokai
to the survivor's camp because it is way
safer than staying at the mall the three
then go to the parking lot where quocay
had parked his car a year ago he tries
to restart it as leeway guards them
against the infected soon the car starts
and they make their way to the
survivor's camp unknown to them a man
dressed as a woman follows them on a
bike he is a spy from the rival camp
that robs and steals the supplies from
the other camps when they get to the
base lee wei makes xiaoqi wear a device
in her mouth so the men would feel safe
around her even though she is immune she
still has the virus in her body meaning
that her kiss is deadly when quote k is
alone with lee wei he modifies the mouth
device so she could open it by herself
then the duo meets the investigation
corps a group formed by the most
courageous men who go into the city to
collect supplies their leader is lee wei
who is now dressed as a woman they plan
to take xiaoqi to the tower and ask
quoke to stay safely at the camp xiaoqi
along with the investigation corps leave
for a convenience store nearby to
collect supplies for their journey back
at the camp koke finds the rival spy
giving information about xiaoki to his
camp he senses that xiaoqi and the
others are in danger and goes to save
them meanwhile the investigation corps
and xiaoqi are attacked by the rival
camp they hold xiaoki hostage but the
sniper from the investigation corps
fires at them starting a shootout koke
arrives at the right moment and brings
xiaoqi to a safer place the shootout
gets intense and most of the members of
the investigation corps are killed the
only survivors left are quokai lee wei
and xiaoqi but before they can flee from
the site the rival group catches them
the leader makes xiaoqi wear the mouth
device to be safe and plans to use her
for his benefit but his plans are ruined
when she takes off the device easily
thanks to the modification quokai made
earlier she then kisses the leader as he
falls to the ground and starts
transforming into a woman his teammates
run away fearing the same fate the
surviving three go to their vehicle
which is now surrounded by infected
women leeway offers to get rid of them
since he is still dressed as a girl he
kills all of them and the three continue
to drive to the tower when they drive
for some minutes leeway asks to get off
the vehicle revealing that he too has
been kissed quocay promises to get
xiaoqi to the tower and says goodbye to
lee wei at night the duo stops to rest
in a secluded area they sit in front of
the fire and drink xiaoqi talks about
her fiance who was killed a year ago
when the virus first started to spread
it turns out that she kissed him not
knowing that she was infected cuouque
comforts her and kisses her hand quokai
is into some risky business the
following day they finally reach the
tower but are disappointed when they see
no one around the duo assumes that the
tower was attacked by the infected as
they brainstorm what they should do next
a group of infected women attack them to
their surprise they are saved by men
from inside a nearby factory it turns
out that the tower is actually an old
factory where a group of soldiers and
scientists have gathered to find the
cure the leader of the tower xiaochang
welcomes them and introduces them to his
right-hand man big p
i was not expecting a name like big p in
this movie they take xiaoqi's blood
samples for further research she then
goes to her room to take a rest while
xiao qiang shows quokai around the
facility he is first taken to the lab
where doctor who is looking at some
blood samples who is an alcoholic who
has a habit of forgetting things but he
is the best of the researchers they have
then cuouquet is taken to the part of
the lab where the infected girls are
being kept so the doctors can study them
but the most surprising part about the
facility is the room where infants are
kept xiaocheng claims that the babies
were rescued recently so koke doesn't
think much of it at night everyone
gathers for dinner doctor who gets
hammered and reveals that to create an
antidote a chemical must be extracted
from xiaoqi's brain and upon extraction
she will die instantly even after that
the antidote won't be enough to save
humanity quokai looks at xiao qiang in
confusion and senses that he knows
everything he quickly pushes xiao chang
aside and runs away with xiaoki
xiaochang big p and the other men follow
them xiaoqi accidentally enters a room
and finds non-infected women inside it
turns out that xiaoqi isn't the only one
who was infected by the virus but before
they can inquire further big p knocks
quocay out when he regains consciousness
he is told that the women who are immune
to the virus are called the wisdom
species they have a rare chemical in
their brains that will help them make
the antidote xiaocheng plans to use them
to study the virus and create a vaccine
to end the pandemic although his motive
is good he plans to kill the women for
something that isn't even guaranteed
moreover he forcefully made his men mate
with the captured wisdom species to give
birth to the babies that quokkai saw
earlier when the women die he plans to
use the babies for the antidote because
they also belong to the wisdom species
kwoke agrees to help xiaoqiang with his
plan for the sake of humanity but asks
to meet xiaoki for the last time he
meets her and tells her about his
decision to help xiao qiang xiaoqi looks
at him in disappointment but before
leaving koke tells xiao chang to make
the woman wear his mouth device when
they are brought outside for surgery
xiaoki gets the hint and explains to all
the girls how they can take off the
mouth device on their own the next day
the girls are made to wear pretty
dresses and are brought to the operation
room they are also made to wear mouth
devices that quokai has secretly
modified as the operation starts they
take the devices off and kiss all the
doctors infecting them meanwhile koke
goes to the area where the infected
women are kept and frees them so they
can attack xiaocheng's men their plan
works and the girls are finally free
they get their kids and run away from
the factory while kwoke stays to
announce the tower's truth to survivors
around china through radio he is soon
attacked by xiaoqiang and the two get
into a fight xiao xiaoqiang is about to
kill him but xiaoqi arrives at the right
time and saves quokkai
however during the struggle xiaoki is
stabbed at last xiaoqi and koke
announced the tower's truth to the
survivors through the radio
they know that there is no chance for
xiaoqi to survive the injury but koke
refuses to let her die alone at last
they joined two wires creating an
explosion to blow up the facility and
sacrificing themselves in the process
outside the surviving wisdom species
watch the place burn with their babies
the movie ends as they walk away
determined to end the pandemic with
their acquired knowledge
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching